ton âge merci monsieur le garde des
sceaux la parole est à monsieur edouard
pour ses amis merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre les départements sont autant
victime que les français de vos choix
vous mener une politique de
désengagement accéléré de l'état en
tenant un double langage consistant à
exiger toujours plus sans le compenser
sortez du déni monsieur le premier
ministre et assumé assumez votre
incapacité à lutter contre le chômage
ses 23 millions d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires non compensés pour le
rsa depuis 2012 juste dans l'oise
assumez votre incapacité à lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine
c'est 15 millions d'euros pour
accueillir les mineurs étrangers isolés
cette année dans mon département assumez
votre incapacité à maîtriser les
finances publiques pour financer vos
cadeaux clientéliste électoralistes
c'est plus de 11 milliards de dotation
globale de fonctionnement au moins pour
les collectivités locales depuis 2014
contrairement à votre gouvernement faire
mieux avec moins nous le faisons dans de
nombreux départements
chez moi c'est 80 millions d'euros
d'économie en deux ans sans augmenter ni
les impôts ni la dette et sans baisser
les investissements mais ces efforts
historiques monsieur le premier ministre
sans réaliser non pas parce que vous
puissiez mener grand train où vous
affranchir des réformes nécessaires
comme vous le faites mais pour tenir nos
engagements à respecter la parole donnée
en somme linverse de votre politique à
l'échelle nationale vous donnez dans une
main vous reprenez le double dans
l'autre à l'image comme le rappelle
notre collègue du sro de ce fonds
d'urgence moitié moins que ce que vous
prenez au département à l'article 14 du
projet de loi de finances de votre
dernier exercice budgétaire monsieur le
premier ministre je vous demande de ne
pas continuer à sacrifier un rouage
essentiel du fonctionnement de la nation
sur lui repose une partie l'équipe
social qui permet à la france de tenir
encore debout malgré le délitement
général auquel a conduit votre politique
sans un langage de vérité vous terminez
votre mandat dans les pires conditions
en laissant nos départements exemple nos
territoires des armées et ceux qui les
habitent révolter contre la parole
publique merci la parole est à monsieur
jean michel bayet ministre ménard du
territoire de la ruralité et des
collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député edouard courtial
je vous rassure les départements comme
je les dis à leur compte dès vendredi à
poitiers sont l'objet de toute la
sollicitude du département du cover lama
dès 2013 dès 2013 le gouvernement de
jean marc ayrault a passé avec
l'association est partout en france
impact confiance de 1 milliard 600
millions au moins de février dernier
avec le premier ministre nous avons reçu
de nouveaux l'adf et à ce moment là le
premier ministre a sur son bureau la
motion du congrès de trois ou à
l'unanimité vous demandiez la recentrer
la saône rsa sans toucher aux recettes
dynamiques que sont les dm théo et la
cvae le premier ministre vous a répondu
favorablement et nous avons
immédiatement engager les discussions
c'est incontestable et que ce soit le
premier chef de délégation ou le
deuxième dès que nous avons commencé la
négociation
mon nid nous ne sommes pas favorables à
la recentralisation
alors que vous l'aviez votée au congrès
de trois donc pour pallier ce manquement
à votre engagement nous avons cette
année créer un fonds de 50 millions
d'euros il sera porté l'an dernier à 200
millions d'euros c'est à dire quatre
fois plus et c'est plus de 40
départements qui se vante t d quand dans
le même temps vos recettes
fonctionnement ont augmenté de plus de 4
milliards d'euros monsieur le député et
que le tralala loi notre a quand même
transférer certaines ont des
comportements les transports
l'action économique vers les régions
c'est quand même 600 millions d'euros
que vous allez récupérer sur l'action
économique sans compter le chiffrage
transport qui n'est pas encore fait dans
vous le voyez monsieur le député le
gouvernement ne laisse pas tomber les
partenaires bien d'autres au contraire
comme jeudi en coinçant qui sont l'objet
de toute façon ici tu